Darth Vader's head if I had lightsabers  for legs  I would continually cut through the  floor and potentially go through the  entire world  I rather speak like Yoda  I would rather fly like Boba Fett and  because flying is cool I would rather  live on n dogs I love Ewoks  I would rather drive an x-wing fighter  because the light side rules I'd rather  go through dinner with a [ __ ] of the  heart because he's so huge they would  probably be the lows of variety for my  menu  I would rather babysit he walks because  JA was a cruel and mean  I'd rather be is parking Phyllis as  Artie because to have all that wisdom  must be kind of a burden  I draw the snogs III Thea because you  decree though I would rather do an  impression of Chewie  you